Кількість зброї, яку Сполучені Штати Америки надали Україні від початку повномасштабного російського вторгнення, вражає.
Від протитанкових ракет Javelin до найсучасніших зенітно-ракетних комплексів Patriot -
США постачає більше, ніж будь-яка інша країна світу.
Якщо скласти разом всю військову допомогу Україні від інших союзників,
то допомога, надана Вашингтоном, удвічі більша.
Внесок США у вигляді зброї, військової техніки, тренувань і всього іншого, що потрібно Україні у війні з Росією,
має вирішальне значення для Києва. Без цього їм було б важко продовжувати захищати себе і,
звичайно, ще важче переходити в контрнаступ.
Забезпечення цього процесу вимагає праці тисяч людей і
грошей мільйонів платників податків. Наразі у цій відпрацьованій системі починають з'являтися тріщини.
То чи можна говорити про те, що потік американської зброї в Україну вже досяг свого піку?
Місто Скрентон у штаті Пенсильванія - рідне місто чинного президента США Джо Байдена.
Тут розташований армійський завод боєприпасів - один із основних виробників популярного
артилерійського снаряду калібру 155 мм, який використовують ЗСУ.
Перед працівниками заводу стоїть масштабне завдання - до кінця року збільшити своє виробництво більш ніж удвічі
аби забезпечити боєприпасами українську артилерію.
Усі наші снаряди ми відправляємо на армійський завод боєприпасів в Айові.
Я знаю, що чоловіки і жінки, які працюють на Скрентонському армійському боєприпасному заводі,
пишаються своєю роботою.
Артилерійські снаряди надважливі на фронті. Це той гуркіт, який солдати чують на задньому плані цілими днями.
І що нерідко стає причиною їх смерті. Завод у Скрентоні може виробляти понад 10 тисяч снарядів на місяць.
Може здатися, що це багато, але українська армія витрачає цю кількість за два дні.
А без постійного постачання цих боєприпасів українські гаубиці не приноситимуть жодної користі.
Безумовно, певні види боєприпасів і зброї закінчуються. Багато уваги приділяється 155-міліметровим
артилерійським боєприпасам. Сполучені Штати надіслали вже
близько півтора мільйона снарядів, але не поспішають надсилати більше,
оскільки наші власні запаси вичерпуються.
Досі більшість зброї, яку США відправили в Україну, була з існуючих запасів.
Постачання відбуваються через механізм президентських повноважень.
Завдяки чому Байден може самостійно схвалювати вантаж за вантажем,
не звертаючись постійно за дозволом до Конгресу.
Крім цього, в рамках Ініціативи сприяння безпеці в Україні Конгрес виділив десятки мільярдів доларів підтримки.
Для того, щоб швидко доставити наявну зброю Україні, використовуються президентські повноваження,
оскільки зброя вже виготовлена і може надійти протягом кількох тижнів. Згідно з механізмом
Ініціативи сприяння безпеці в Україні, озброєння треба ще виготовити,
а це займає кілька років і здебільшого буде направлене на післявоєнне забезпечення української армії.
Іншими словами, військова допомога Україні не є безкінечною. Вона обмежена зокрема тим,
що на виробництво зброї потрібен час.
Завод у Скрентоні - не єдине місце, де посилюється виробництво.
За перші вісім місяців повномасштабної війни українські війська використали стільки
протитанкових ракет Javelin, скільки виготовляється за п’ять років. Тепер приватні оборонні корпорації
отримали щедрі державні контракти на подвоєння виробництва.
Ці контракти фінансуються платниками податків, а отже, в кінцевому підсумку залежать від підтримки американських
виборців. Одразу після вторгнення 60 відсотків американців підтримували постачання зброї.
Але до першої річниці війни ця підтримка впала до менш ніж 50 відсотків. А 29 відсотків взагалі виступають
нині проти постачання зброї Україні.
Гадаю, існує певна втома від теми України. Однак все ще існує дуже сильна двопартійна підтримка
допомоги Україні, тому я не думаю, що найближчим часом відбудуться зміни. Але немає сумнівів,
що як серед популістських правих партій, так і серед лівих, зростає занепокоєння щодо того,
як довго триватиме ця війна і якою буде її ціна.
Серед тих, хто проти поставок зброї, є ті, хто принципово виступає проти воєн, особливо тих, що фінансується
завдяки підтримці Вашингтону.
Організація Code Pink та коаліція ANSWER організували протести, на які зібралися тисячі людей у Вашингтоні.
Вони могли б сьогодні взяти ручку для нотаток, підняти слухавку і сказати: "Давайте почнемо переговори".
Це врятувало б незліченну кількість життів, незліченну кількість ресурсів, які можна було б спрямувати на
відновлення цієї країни. Неможливо побачити шлях до миру, коли відбувається постійна ескалація і безперервне
постачання зброї, аж допоки Україна не перетвориться на цвинтар.
Але найбільш значний політичний опір поставкам зброї на даний момент іде від правого крила політичних партій.
Напередодні майбутніх президентських виборів, що відбудуться наступного року, опоненти президента Байдена
від республіканців, обидва лідери партії Дональд Трамп і Рон Десантіс розкритикували політику нинішнього уряду
щодо підтримки України.
У нещодавньому інтерв'ю CNN Трамп відмовився казати, що підтримує надання більшої кількості зброї Україні.
Чи надали б ви Україні зброю і фінансування, якби вас обрали президентом?
Скажу простіше. Якщо я буду президентом, я закінчу цю війну за один день, за 24 години.
До виборів ще більше року. Але кілька чинних членів Конгресу від Республіканської партії закликали
до негайного припинення поставок.
Позиція, що ми озброюємо до зубів будь-кого, хто буде стріляти в росіян, насправді не завжди спрацьовувала
для Америки.
Ніяких грошей Україні! Цій країні потрібен мир, а не війна.
Нестихаючі овації на конференції республіканців, що проходила у березні.
Більшість виборців Республіканської партії нині не підтримують надання Україні зброї.
На чолі цієї опозиції - конгресмени Метт Гейц і Марджорі Тейлор Грін. Незадовго до річниці повномасштабної війни
Гейц представив у Палаті представників резолюцію "Втома від України", в якій закликав США "припинити військову
та фінансову допомогу Україні".
Я намагався поговорити з усіма 11 авторами цієї резолюції, але вони або не відповідали на мої листи, або відмовлялися
говорити зі мною. І я вирішив піти до Капітолію і поговорити з представником Ральфом Норманом.
Я звидувався почутому.
Резолюція про "втому від України"?
Я її не бачив. Не читав.
Ні?
Можливо, він забув, що поставив під нею своє ім'я. Загальне враження було таке, що резолюція
не є серйозною, неважливою навіть для її авторів.
Але це не те, про що говорить і просить президент України Володимир Зеленський - неохоче продовжувати
підтримувати у форматі статусу-кво. Він чітко дав зрозуміти, що навіть зараз,
після отримання мільярдної військової допомоги і обіцянок надати ще мільярди,
Україна все ще не має достатньо зброї, необхідної для того, щоб витіснити російські війська зі своєї території.
Велика перемога полягає в тому, щоб змусити уряд США надати Україні достатньо інструментів для перемоги,
а не лише для виживання.
Це Карл Ларсон, ветеран армії США. Минулого року кілька тижнів він провів у Інтернаціональному легіоні в Україні.
Ларсон каже, що брак спорядження коштував одному з його товаришів життя.
Це осколок снаряда, який вбив його і ледь не вбив мене. Він влучив у нього, а у нас не було генератора, тому батареї
на наших раціях не працювали. І у нас не було машини, щоб його вивезти.
На його черевиках і досі, як каже чоловік, залишилися плями від крові товариша.
Більшість американців думають, що ми відправили 100 мільярдів доларів, і вони, мабуть, їздять там на позолочених
танках, так? Ні. У них взимку навіть теплих черевиків не вистачає.
Ларсон зібрав понад 100 тисяч доларів на придбання нелетального військового спорядження і відправив
його українським солдатам.
Нам видали літні спальники. Більшість моїх хлопців отримали зимові спальники лише в лютому.
Тож вони буквально загорталися в мішки для сміття. Тут багато різних речей, які ми не будемо перераховувати.
Наколінники, дрони, паракордовий шнур, павербанки - дуже важливі речі.
Це дійсно гарний прилад. Ви можете використовувати його як тримач для планшета, він кріпиться ось тут.
Він кріпиться прямо сюди замість цього чохла. Також можна кріпити і на грудях: кладете сюди свій телефон,
і тоді, коли ви на маневрах, можете ось так подивитися, куди вам треба йти.
Ларсон перебуває у Вашингтоні не лише для того, щоб говорити про збір коштів.
Його діяльність полягає також у зустрічах із американськими законодавцями та їхніми радниками,
закликаючи їх до більших і якісніших поставок озброєнь.
Що нелегко, бо дедалі більше американців ставлять під сумнів витрати на підтримку України.
Великий страх у багатьох викликає те, що називають "вічною війною".
Тобто "Невже ми будемо витрачати сім мільярдів доларів на місяць безкінечно?". Ось чому для України важливо
продемонструвати певний прогрес у своєму контрнаступі. Звичайно, Україна хоче звільнити свою територію,
але це ще й важливо з дипломатичної і політичної точок зору.
Бо це покаже, що Україна досягає певного прогресу, що це не буде вічною війною, що врешті-решт ми дійдемо до етапу,
коли Україна буде в набагато кращій ситуації.